[Music]
[Applause]
so if you're in the audience today or
maybe you're watching this talk in some
other time or place you are a
participant in the digital rights
ecosystem and whether you're an artist a
technologist a lawyer
or a fan the handling of copyright
directly impacts your life
now rights management is no longer
simply a question of ownership it's a
complex web of relationships in a
critical part of our cultural landscape
a YouTube cares deeply about the rights
of content owners but in order to give
them choices about what they can do with
copies mashups and more we need to first
identify when copyrighted material is
uploaded to our site let's look at a
specific video so you can see how it
works
two years ago recording artist Chris
Brown released the official video of his
single forever a fan saw it on TV
recorded it with her camera phone and
uploaded it to YouTube now because Sony
Music had registered Chris Brown's video
and our Content ID system within seconds
of attempting to upload the video the
copy was detected giving Sony the choice
of what to do next but how do we know
that the users video is a copy well it
starts with content owners delivering
assets into our database along with a
usage policy that tells us what to do
when we find a match we compare each
upload against all of the reference
files in our database now this heat map
is going to show you how the brain of
the system works here we can see the
original reference file being compared
to the user generated content the system
compares every moment of one to the
other to see if there's a match now this
means that we can identify a match even
if the copy uses just a portion of the
original file plays it in slow motion
and has degraded audio and video quality
and we do this every time that a video
is uploaded to YouTube and that's over
20 hours of video every minute when we
find a match we apply the policy that
the rights owner has set down and the
scale and the speed of this system is
truly breathtaking we're not just
talking about a few videos we're
I'm talking about over a hundred years
of video every day between new uploads
and the legacy scans we regularly do
across all of the content on the site
and when we compare those hundred years
of video we're comparing it against
millions of reference files in our
database
it'd be like 36,000 people staring at
36,000 monitors each and every day
without so much as a coffee break now
what do we do when we find a match well
most rights owners instead of blocking
will allow the copy to be published and
then they benefit through the exposure
advertising and linked sales remember
Chris Brown's video forever well it had
its day in the Sun and that had dropped
off the charts and that looked like the
end of the story but sometime last year
a young couple got married this is their
wedding video you may have seen it
what's amazing about this is if the
processional of the wedding was this
much fun can you imagine how much fun
the reception must have been I mean who
are these people I totally want to go to
that wedding so their little wedding
video went on to get over 40 million
views and instead of Sony blocking they
allowed the upload to occur and they put
advertising against it and linked from
it to iTunes and the song 18 months old
went back to number four on the iTunes
charts so Sony is generating revenue
from both of these and Jill and Kevin
the happy couple they came back from
their honeymoon and found that their
video had gone crazy viral and they
ended up on a bunch of talk shows and
they used it as an opportunity to make a
difference the videos inspired over
$26,000 in donations to end domestic
violence and the JK wedding dance became
so popular that NBC parodied it on the
season finale of The Office which just
goes to show it's truly an ecosystem of
culture is it's not just amateurs
borrowing from big studios but sometimes
big studios borrowing back by empowering
choice we can create a culture of
opportunity and all I took to change
things around was to allow for choice
through rites identification so why is
no one ever solved this problem before
it's because it's a big problem and it's
complicated and messy
it's not uncommon for a single video to
have multiple rights owners
there's musical labels there's multiple
music publishers and each of these can
vary by country and there's lots of
cases where we have more than one work
mash together so we have to manage many
who claims to the same video YouTube's
Content ID system addresses all of these
cases but the system only works for the
participation of rights owners if you
have content that others are uploading
to YouTube you should register in the
Content ID system and then you'll have
the choice about how your content is
used and think carefully about the
policies that you attach to that content
by simply blocking all reuse you'll miss
out on new art forms new audiences new
distribution channels and new revenue
streams but it's not just about dollars
and impressions just look at all the joy
that was spread through progressive
rights management and new technology and
I think we can all agree that joy is
definitely an idea worth spreading thank
you
[Applause]
investment in broadband high-speed
Internet can help small businesses
create new American jobs small
businesses are being formed dreams are
being launched and at AT&T we're
investing billions to upgrade and build
out our wired and wireless networks now
is not the time to stall momentum or
stifle innovation or investment jobs
dreams and the future are at stake AT&T
your world delivered